First candy bars, then butter. Fried beer was inevitable.
Here's how to get two American favorites,...
...beer and deep - fried dough in one finger-lickin' good package.
You will need one tablespoon yeast, one cup lukewarm water,...
...one tablespoon sugar, three and a half cups flour, a third cup butter,...
...one teaspoon salt, three eggs, beer, and two cups vegetable oil.
Equipment:...
...a rolling pin, a ravioli cutter,...
...a candy and oil thermometer, and a slotted spoon.
Step one: Make pretzel dough by combining the yeast, water, and sugar until they dissolve.
Then beat in one cup of the flour and let the mixture stand until it's frothy.
Finally, add the salt, butter, and the rest of the flour,...
...and knead the dough until the butter is distributed.
Step two: Roll out the dough into thin sheets.
Beat the eggs together and brush the sheets with egg...
...and then use the ravioli cutter to press ravioli shapes out of the dough.
Step three: Pair the shapes and press them together on three sides,...
...egg wash sides facing.
Use your thumb to hold the pocket open while you press the sides together.
Step four: Prop the raviolis against each other with the open end up and pour beer into the pockets.
Then, press the open ends closed to seal the beer inside.
Step five: Heat the oil in a pan until it measures 325°F on the thermometer.
Then, in small batches, fry the ravioli for about 20 seconds.
Step six: Use the slotted spoon to remove the fried ravioli to paper towels to soak up excess oil.
Allow them to cool for a few minutes and pop a shot of deep - fried beer.
Did you know the Miller Brewing Company was founded in 1855...
...when Frederick J. Miller bought the Plank Road Brewery in Milwaukee, Wisconsin?